foreign
Beverly Is With Us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Beverly welcome to the ram station
hello Dave how are you doing doctor how
are you doing we are better than we
deserve how can we help
I'm trying to get there too okay this is
my situation my
mine's done 21
St without a will I was not living but
then we've been like separated but not
legally for about two decades we have
children and which are grown of course
and um like I'm trying to do this
probate thing my problem is that I have
to hire a appropriate attorney because
what he did he did own a house okay it
has has a tax value of like 170 which I
think is flying out because he didn't
take care of it and the problem I'm
having with um probate is because he
didn't file um taxes with me within the
last um two years one or two years
um I have proof um have difficulty
proving that we've never done a divorce
because in Philadelphia
the rules state that um okay
um that you have to do the taxes you
know if you um because they cannot tell
there's no divorce record do you
understand where I'm going with it they
can't prove that you were married at the
time
so I'm having to go to this um
yeah that sounds backwards right right
he lived in he lived in Philadelphia
and I live in Atlanta okay and uh you've
been separated for 10 years that's weird
well more than more than 10 really
that's whacked okay so why do you think
you get the house because you basically
were divorced
why well we're divorce of Legally uh I
understand but why do you even think you
get the house morally
You've Been Gone Girl
why not I mean what's along with that I
mean I wasn't asking about the law I was
asking about what's right you weren't
married for the last 10 years plus 20
years 20 years in a very real way I mean
technically you are because you guys are
weird but you said you said you've been
doing your taxes together up until two
years ago we have not been doing our
attacks together but I have been
receiving so we're both um a veterans
right I'm a disabled veteran I have been
receiving
um been um veteran and Social Security
pension through him
and me because I served also but I
received you know through him
all these years until the day he died
yeah and I guess whatever widows uh
because you're still technically married
you get that and the Veterans
Administration probably isn't looking
into it but when you went to Probate
Court uh the people in Philadelphia went
uh you kind of like need to show us
you're not divorced and two years of tax
returns would do that uh obviously the
law in Pennsylvania is not that if
people don't file married filing jointly
for two whole years that they are
automatically divorced Under
Pennsylvania law that is not the case uh
so something else is going on here when
you went into probate I know like
somebody's fighting you like one of the
kids says you shouldn't get this house
no no the kids are you know backing me
up which I could do okay
um have one of the children go up there
but um we did take a trip up there but
this paperwork was wrong and I'm just
like tired of you know spending my money
supplying the house worth actually if
you were to put it on the market with a
real estate agent
[Music]
um that's another thing too the tax leg
in the house is 170 right but it's in
poor shape what is the code what would
the house sell for if you put it on with
a real estate agent
when a real estate agent I might get 174
with you know the tax value of it okay
so if you could if you could sell it for
170 because you're not moving to
Philadelphia that's what you're going to
do with it then uh what's it what's owed
against it
also my like 17
000 in back taxes that's all I am paying
yeah which I am paying you know once you
got a payment he had no mortgage
no he had no mortgage now
okay what do you make
what I mean I make um through my VA
Social Security like forty eight hundred
dollars how old are you
oh I am 63. okay here's what I would do
I'm the same age as you okay getting
ready to be I'm 62. if I woke up in your
shoes
um which I can't imagine but if I did
because I got to tell you if I left
Sharon for 20 years one of us would be
dead but yeah
anyway
but if I woke up in your
should do I
would I would hire to get a 170 000
asset as the wife of a dead guy
um The Legal Wife of a dead guy no
divorce occurred and uh there's no one
arguing about this no one's anything we
just need to get the house deeded to you
so you can sell it you need a judge's
order from probate court to be able to
sell the house I would just hire a
probate attorney
that's what I did I I mentioned it and
they said you just can't do it it's
impossible no he didn't say he didn't do
it I just want to make sure that I'm
doing this because I love the way you
know if somebody's doing something
stupid lady I love the way you tell them
hey you're being a fool okay no you're
not you're not being a fool if you're
hired an attorney to work you through
this very complicated and uh unusual
situation
um you're not being a fool at all in
that regard no no and uh because you
need to get basically you need to get a
judge's order in Probate Court to be
able to give to the title company so
they can issue a title because the guy
that's on the title is not here to sign
it
and so the you know the you have a
ruling from the judge that allows the
title company to write title insurance
and the judge is going to say oh okay
this lady's the they never they're they
were separated forever but they never
got a divorce and there's no
Pennsylvania law that makes you
instantly divorced and so we're going to
issue a ruling that says this house is
to be sold and um
Miss Beverly from Atlanta can sign the
deed and you mentioned I heard you
mention that you had to protect your
children
um
if they give you grief over it you can
tell them no he he left or I left keep
us safe and we just never got to run to
the divorce it does it you are going to
have to explain that at some point why
you didn't never file on him whether he
was she just mentioned that whether he
was abusive or he wasn't safe to be
around
um oh is that why she said she laughed
oh okay okay um said she had to protect
her children which I understand well
that's a different issue but I also
understand
um the divorce process is messy if
somebody wants to drag it out I get all
that but 20 years is a long time a long
long time now closure closure's worth
your time and your money yes yeah
painter get off the ladder yeah that's
that's the plan